Good afternoon.
I hope, like me, everyone brought sunscreen here to sunny
San Diego.
Today's
methods workshop is titled "Deep Learning in Digital Pathology: From
Morphology to Digital Biomarkers." And we've designed a series of
talks that will walk you through both the
basics of applying digital deep learning methods,
contemporary AI methods for computer vision to digital pathology
substrate,
through to clinical application and the development of biomarkers, and then
onto the integration of multiple forms of data simultaneously
with digital pathology as the underpinning.
So we're really excited to share these complementary set of talks with you
today.
All right. My name is Alex Pearson. I'll be chairing the session.
And I'm a medical oncologist and computational scientist at University of Chicago.
The title of my talk is called "Fundamentals of Deep Learning for Digital
Pathology."
So today's talk, I want to cover the
basic concepts to give us a shared language and some
fundamentals about the topic of deep learning for digital pathology.
So I'm going to start with the broader context about why digital pathology is
important to us in cancer research.
I'm going to talk about the fundamentals of the data structure itself,
as well as key tasks we can hope to accomplish using deep learning
for digital pathology.
I'll next talk about some of the underlying methods
for deep learning models, as well as this emerging field of foundation
models that you'll hear a lot about at this year's AACR conference.
I'll touch on some of the most common use cases, where folks have been
thinking about deploying
deep learning-based models for digital pathology.
And then we'll talk a little bit about some of the potential pitfalls of which
there are many in AI for digital pathology,
as well as some considerations for deployment.
So starting with the broader context, why are we having this
session now? Well, I think the
structure, the rationale for why this
area is changing so quickly is that the field of clinical
pathology and cancer or oncologic pathology in
general as well,
is increasingly a digital field.
Storage costs on glass remain constant, if not increasing,
and there's an increasing access through institutional investment in whole slide
imaging, allowing the substrate of pathology to be
digitized at its source.
There's
more and more medical centers or healthcare systems
have a distributed model for surgical cases, in which
case a surgical center may be manned remotely by a
pathologist who is responsible for covering multiple sites, and
that's only possible with a distributed digital format.
Digital format also allows for a much improved or a
redundancy in data storage as opposed to glass, which
exists in only one context and can be destroyed, for example.
And there's increasingly an appetite for efficiency and
reproducibility in clinical pathology,
which argue for the use of automated
models like can be accomplished with deep learning.
So hematoxylin and eosin stained slides and digital
pathology in general is really a good substrate for building and deploying
AI models because the data is ubiquitous and global.
It's inexpensive to produce, it's biologically
expressive,
representing many different genotypes and phenotypes, and
it's already integrated into clinical practice.
So these are reasons why many in the community
have picked up on digital pathology as a good place to deploy AI
models.
I'll give an example here, but just in terms of the biological expressivity
and the context of the data, you can see that a single digital pathology
slide contains an incredible amount of information across many different
orders of magnitude of scale and results in
information about global morphologic features as well as
single cell interactions.
So let's talk a little bit about that data, just so we're
covering the fundamentals.Digital pathology exists in a
pyramidal structure, which
exists across many orders of magnitude of resolution.
And so we can get both global views of full tissue
scale samples in one-to-one resolution, as well as
very granular microscopic views of what's happening in
tumor microenvironments. So this data structure allows us to deploy
models at a variety of different scales or multiple scales at the same time in
some cases.
And the process by which the
glass digital pathology slide is digitized can
vary from institution to institution or even from lab to lab.
But fundamentally, it follows a similar process.
Stained
tissue on glass slides are digitized using, for example,
a whole slide image
microscope or digital slide scanner.
There may be an interaction with a pathologist to
QC to check the
digital image substrate, for example, or to provide some additional context or
annotation.
The
digital slide may be processed using one or more
subtypes of
image modification, and may be tiled or sliced
into more computationally tractable parts depending on the
algorithm. We'll talk a little bit more about how foundation models fit
in, but essentially at the point of the digital
substrate creation, then information can be
processed using one or more different concepts
and passed downstream to the end result analysis.
So there are many possible tasks that can be
accomplished using deep learning models for digital
pathology.
I've shown here an example wherein an input image
which might be representing a hematologic malignancy,
could be processed using, for example, a deep convolutional neural network model,
and
then a variety of different tasks could be accomplished.
For example,
we might seek to detect the presence of a
malignant cell,
or we could seek to segment or outline the area
of a nuclei or subcellular organelle.
We might seek to classify the image into one or more
classes, or two or more classes. In other words, a subtype
of malignant leukemia, or we might even augment the image,
meaning improve its detail and its
interpretability. And all of those contexts might be
explained using a parallel set of methods that allow better
interpretability.
So with these concepts in mind,
I want to talk a little bit more about the methods that underpin
this field of study, and this emerging field of
foundation models which are becoming increasingly used
in digital pathology and in other fields.
The key architectural components that have been used most frequently in digital
pathology are convolutional neural networks and vision transformers.
These are two separate computational tools that I'm illustrating
with
GIFs here.
On the left, the convolutional neural network
processes or passes the
intensity of pixels through a kernel function, which
multiplies each pixel by a weight and
then aggregates those weights in a subsequent layer of a
many-layered neural network.
The weights are iteratively updated over millions of iterations,
moving tiny amounts closer
to a place where it satisfies or approaches an objective
function or a loss function
which is housed in an equation at the far end of the neural network stack.
So over very long periods of time, or very many iterations, I should
say, the convolutional neural network learns how to
see, learns how to understand patterns underlying image features.
A vision transformer model, on the other hand, is a more contemporary model
and uses a more language-inspired concept
wherein an extracted
subcomponent of information from imaging features is
attached to a spatial label,
and then processed through a
format very similar to those that are used in contemporary large
language models.
Similarly, building a recognition of images
over very many iterations.
Vision transformer models are now being
integrated into a new class of models called foundation models,
which are unsupervised models which learn
a language to describe the variation space
in the digital pathology architecture.
So
the
architecture that is used to build a foundation model is designed
to encourage
two parallel vision transformer systems to
recognize and come to the same conclusions about a
set of related cropped images. And in
this way, over
many passes through the system, a
shared language is developed, where the student and teacher
have
established a learning without needing to be provided with explicit
labels. So this foundation model concept is very popular
because it allows us to generate a
set of... defining language-like
characteristics which describe the full
variation space of the
exposed
information. So
the downside of foundation models is that they require abundant amounts of
information. So this is a schema from the Virchow 2 foundation
model.
And it has required, or in this case, has been trained on
1.5 million hematoxylin and eosin stain slides from
120,000 patients worth of information.
That's a
huge amount of training information that requires
careful thought and organization in order to
be able to develop such a model.
There are many
pathology foundation models in existence now.
Many of them use shared underlying architectures.
And as you can see, they
vary in terms of the total number of slides that have been used for training.
I'll also note I've appended here two of the benchmarking
studies that have been accomplished to help compare the
performance and use characteristics of some of these foundation models.
And so I'll leave this up for a second for your
review and capture.
So to review, a foundation model
produces this dramatically reduced complexity feature
vector or encoding to represent the patterns of an image.
And so you could think of this as we do as the omics of digital
pathology data. And just to summarize, this complex
spatial data can be processed to a foundation model, returning a
vector of
variables which can then be fine-tuned using regression models or
machine learning models to a fine-tuned clinical application
downstream.
And just to say, this opportunity is a tie-in to one
of our later lectures from Professor Wang, and this is a really
useful way to integrate multiple data modes
simultaneously. All right, so let's talk about some use cases in
cancer for deep learning methods for pathology.
I think I'd be remiss without saying that our field has moved forward, and
just within the last year, there's now a FDA-cleared breakthrough
designation AI-based digital pathology tool, which is a
companion diagnostic for an antibody drug conjugate for Trop2.
And it requires
the algorithm itself, as well as a proprietary image management system,
digital pathology scanners of a certain make and model, as well as
a companion assay. So obviously a lot needs to go in for
a rigorous and reproducible digital pathology AI biomarker, but
this is really exciting for the field in that we now have
an AI model leading us to make
selections on behalf of our patients.
Outside of
the clinical use case, there's been abundant research in
AI for human disease. So just in terms of
pathology alone, this is a
review and meta-analysis of AI detection for
pathologic identification of
disease in any organ.
And this was almost 3,000 studies identified for this
meta-analysis. I'll note, and we'll touch on this in the future,
that the vast majority of these studies, even though there's a huge number of
applications, in the studies that exist, most had some
concern for the presence of bias. And so the
forward-looking application of these concepts needs to be handled with
caution.
One of the most appealing use cases
from my perspective as a researcher is this kind of superhuman
potential of identifying
concepts that might shortcut, might speed our
application of precision medicine to the clinic.
And so in work led by Jakob Kathe's group,
we sought to
identify whether or not we could find
mutation classes directly from the digital pathology
substrate. And indeed, there were many actionable genetic
mutations which were present in the most common subtypes of
cancers as represented
in the area under the receiver operator curve
on the tables listed here.
But we weren't yet able to deploy them
or identify them with enough accuracy to be ready for prime time and
clinical deployment. I think we were heartened by some of the titration studies
that have been done, for example, on the right, where when a deep learning
model is given more data, generally the model is able to
perform better, even when
validated on the same left out data set.
And so this gave us
an optimistic view that we may be able to accomplish this relevant
task in the future. And indeed, this is a preprint
link from the MSK group.
And they looked at a relevant or a parallel topic where
they evaluated the MSK Impact data set with more than
80,000 samples,
paired digital pathology and clinical genomics, and were able to achieve
some really, really
exciting performance
in terms of identifying some of the most common genetic alterations
in a variety of different cancers.
And this has been validated on external cohorts as well.
We're going to hear from Professor Campanella's talk about
what deployment of a genetic
identifier, a genetic mutation identifying deep learning
model looks like in
practice.So I think we
have and will continue to see a rapid growth both in the
research and clinical FDA approval domains leveraging digital
pathology.
All right. So let's talk a little bit about some of the pitfalls and some of the
potentials for deployment of deep learning models.
So this is
data from Fred Howard's lab at University of Chicago
and it's meant to provoke some thought.
These are models that were trained to predict ancestry
directly from the digital pathology slides of patients
from a variety of different ancestral backgrounds in a variety of different tumor
types.
And so these
models were able to predict the ancestry with really high
accuracy. So as a thought experiment, do you think this represents
the biological basis of potentially cancer disparities, something
identifiable in the tumor tissue that is
relevant and worth further study?
And
I'll say that we were initially really excited about this
until we realized that there were some idiosyncrasies with the
data that were biasing our models.
And indeed, these were models built on the Cancer Genome Atlas,
and there was this extremely strong association between the
donating sites in the Cancer Genome Atlas and the
ancestral origin. So almost all the Asian
American patients included in the Cancer Genome Atlas came from one site in the Bay
Area, and the plurality of African American
patients donated tumors came from University of Chicago and a few other
sites. And so the AI model was lazy and
was able to identify some of the associations that are
spurious and non-biological.
I'll say that it gets even trickier with contemporary deep learning
digital pathology models. This is some additional unpublished data
from our lab, and it shows a
precisely harmonized set of digital
pathology images where the same exact tiles are
captured on different slide scanners and then the
digital locations are precisely aligned and
the features are then extracted using the same set
of foundation models. What you're seeing here is the noise that is
induced
from the exact same source data and the exact same pipeline simply from the
microscope itself.
This is a
lot of noise
for something that we think of as just processing
information without a substantial amount of
alteration.
So I think this field of bias in
AI-based models is not new and has been identified
in a number of different contexts.
Judy Gichoya has done some amazing work
showing where bias can be introduced in a model everywhere from the data
collection to the implementation stage, and I think it's
a caution to all of us that the AI models that we're using
probably are picking up bias in every one of these places
and more that we haven't yet identified.
There are fortunately many different methods to
help mitigate some of this bias. I'll note some of them here.
Color normalization is a way to help
harmonize site-specific information, and batch effect
mitigation are methods
oftentimes borrowed from
the genomic literature to help harmonize the features
or the information that is processed via digital pathology in order
to make the models more comparable,
minimizing some of the noise that we have seen from different sites
in the past few slides.
One other way that I think is part of standard practice
is evaluating the model
or explanations of the model-based predictions.
And there's a series where
a typical standard practice would be returning to the
images themselves with some of these explainability methods and
making sure that the areas of attention that a model is applying
are not associated with things like pen marks
or stain characteristics, but rather
identifying biological class characteristics.
Our group has explored a concept where we've used
synthetic images
in order to explain and ensure that our models are
trustworthy. And I'll give an example of this on the right where
in a model trained to identify thyroid
neoplasm subtypes, we can embed, encode the same seed
image in information that represents either a BRAF-like
or RAS-like mutation pattern. And this
information contained enough visual cues
that we actually could train a series of human
pathologists to recognize these molecular states
and
after a period of training with the synthetic generative adversarial neural
network-based images, the human pathologists improved in their
performance of this task even
predicting the mutation class on glass slides.
So the encoding in synthetic
images contains a robust amount and reproducible amount of
information.
Other tools for deployment include a variety of different
pipelines that
are platforms that have end-to-end
deployment features. Our lab produced this SlideFlow
platform which includes all of the typical models
for batch mitigation... slide color
normalization and accommodates any number of different foundation models for
training, and allows for end-to-end deployment of
a digital pathology AI model on any new set
of tissue. So
just to give a sense of how close to deployment we are,
I'll show an example here of a full
end-to-end
desktop concept that we've been working on.
And so this is a modular format that we stitched together just to show
how the concepts could be deployed in real-world settings.
And you're going to see some more concepts of this in the next lecture.
But this uses this
purchasable desktop digital slide scanner, which is
made by a Finnish company. It has a really appealing open
API,
and it allows you to interact and select a sub-region that
you want to focus on for a digital pathology integration.
We've used this open API with our open source SlideFlow
software in order just to house and manage the
information. And to show the general applicability,
we pulled down an open source model that was published
by Yakub Cather's group to predict microsatellite instability,
and integrated that into this pipeline just to show how
the concept could be deployed. Now,
I think that it's worth saying here that we imagine a future state where the
same concept might have a suite or a zoo of different models that could
be integrated simultaneously, and you could select the one
that was most applicable, for example, for your patient.
And so, as a medical oncologist, I think about using
a desktop format so that we can avoid the
delays that come with institutional batched slide scanning,
potentially,
and speed the diagnostic information into the hands of
a
decision-making provider as quickly as possible.
So, in the time I've been talking,
the scanner has now completed its
high-resolution acquisition.
And it's stitching together the
portion of identified whole slide image, and allowing us to
then pass it,
the high-resolution image, on to the analytic deep learning based software.
So we can just drop the image into the
platform.
The area of tumor can then be identified and discriminated from
other artifacts, like the pen marks that you see.
And in the time I've been talking, the model can be run for inference.
And so this
was a microsatellite stable
sample, and in the time I've been talking, we have this molecular
inference returned in the digital pathology image.
So I think deployment of precision oncology
tools leveraging deep learning to identify relevant molecular subtypes
is within immediate reach.
So to summarize, digital pathology AI analysis methods combine innumerable simple
calculations in order to accomplish complex tasks.
Contemporary deep digital pathology models benefit from immense
training volumes but still need supervision fine-tuning to prevent biased
results. And deep learning models can be
applied to digital pathology to complete a huge number of downstream tasks.
So with that, I will conclude my first set of remarks,
and we have time for one question before we move to the
next speaker. Thanks.
You
can submit a question online or come to the podiums up here,
and make sure to speak into the podium so the online
participants can hear.
Hi.
Hello. Very nice talk. So, I want to ask a question about the
CHOP2
companion diagnostic is still an IHC-based
product, right? So then, for the H&E
only based methods,
in the future it will be a suggestive or
actually, for a more conclusive diagnostic
application like companion, you have to actually use IHC.
Well,
maybe. I will say that there's European CE marked
digital pathology tools that use H&E-
Mm-hmm
... not IHC. And so this is an example of a
digital pathology tool that's not H&E based, but rather IHC based,
and is FDA breakthrough designation.
So
I think that so long as the validation has been
completed, I don't think that there needs-- The analytics is what's been
done in terms of a pattern recognition perspective.
Thanks. And secondly, very quickly, so the biomarker for
the CHOP2-ADC is CHOP2. So it's
very straightforward, but it seems to be there's no learning needed here.
So do you think when we have a better data set and
so on, we actually can have a better biomarker?
Yeah. So I would argue that
one of the promises of digital pathology deep learning is that
it can improve the
reproducibility and accuracy even when there's a biological
correlate. So I didn't talk a lot about IHC based
deep learning models, but for example,
the concordance
for a deep learning model that uses
HER2 as an IHC substrate is better than
human scoring of HER2 when you look at
HER2 targeting endpoints. SoI think that
any
AI model potentially could improve the rigor
and reproducibility of the identification and
the relevant subpatterns that an IHC
biomarker can deliver.
I think it just requires an appropriate amount of information in order to
make that leap, make that association between the
endpoint and the data.
Okay, we have
35 seconds.
Okay. Quick question. Nice talk. So my
question is regarding the tumors
of unknown origin that are poorly differentiated.
Do you have any data regarding how digital pathology will help
on that?
I didn't show in my talk, but
a number of groups have published
papers on this topic. I think one that comes to mind is from Faisal
Mahmood's lab that has done this task of identifying
the tumor of origin using, I believe, a molecular
gold standard against a digital pathology substrate, and
showed that they were able to identify a putative tumor of origin in a
carcinoma of unknown primary with really appealing accuracy.
So I think you're spot on that this is a good place to
apply a deep learning model.
Thank you.
Thanks. All right. With that, we'll
pass the mic over to our second speaker.
So I'm pleased to introduce Gabriele Cambiamalla from Mount Sinai who will
talk about implementation in his talk.
Thank
you.
Alex is way taller than me.
Alex invited me today to talk about what we did about implementation of
AI models for pathology,
so I hope you will find this interesting.
So first I want to talk a little bit about the
current state of deployment of AI models.
I know Alex already went through a little bit, but I guess I want to give it my
spin. And then the
second half is going to be about what we did, and I hope that
stimulates your
ideas.
So
when I want to talk about pathology in the wild, I think we have to touch on
three main things,
digital pathology, computational pathology, and then the
regulatory aspect.
So in terms of digital pathology,
we know that
adoption of digital pathology maybe is not at the level
that we would like. So definitely there is still many more
hospitals that rely on microscopes and not on digital
pathology. So some data that was trying to gather
recent
publication where they estimate that fewer than 15%
of healthcare organizations are at any stage of
digital pathology adoption. So we're far from
being ubiquitous.
So it's important to consider if we don't have the digital component, then we
cannot deploy AI.
The second part is the actual products
potentially that we want to deploy, so the computational pathology
component.
And if you look through the life cycle now, there is a ton of
projects maybe at the pilot level, and as you
follow the life cycle, the numbers really
decrease rapidly.
So
I did a quick
PubMed query here for computational pathology.
It looks like the field is exploding.
It does feel that way as well,
which is great.
On the other hand, though, if we look at some publications about
adoption of these models,
we see a different picture. So in 2021, there was
one FDA approval
for AI in pathology.
And a more recent study on the right, we see maybe three,
and this is a bit old by now. Maybe there is a couple more in the last year.
But still quite far from what we see in other fields, for example.
So there's definitely a
huge bottleneck.
And then that gets compounded with the
regulatory
environment, which is a bit uncertain at the moment, I think,
or at least that's how I perceive it.
And if you have a different perspective, come talk.
I would like to hear your perspective.
And another thing,
it's guidelines, it's
regulation,
and there's been some
places, for example, in Europe where they're starting to provide
actual guidelines
for the
development and deployment of these AI models and
biomarkers from pathology.
Okay, so
we saw that AI adoption for pathology is low.
I guess I didn't show you,
but there's been many AI wins in pathology,
definitely a lot of publications here, like some of our publication
diagnostic and biomarker space. But
even in this conference, you're going to hear a lot of talks about
pathology and there is
many wins
in the field.So why?
And it gets even worse to me because we're facing
quite troubling
workforce
issues in pathology.
So there's a worldwide shortage of pathologists.
So not just some countries,
really worldwide, US, Canada, UK,
everywhere. The pathologist workforce is aging,
and the workloads are increasing.
Now there's more cancer incidents.
The complexity is increasing with precision oncology and all
the tests that they have to do. And this already is having negative effects on
healthcare delivery.
So burnout and the amount of time that people have to wait for
their results. Now, all of this, we're already seeing these
effects.
So AI could be a part of
the solution here.
And so one of the things that I guess I'm proposing today is that
to solve this bottleneck that we're seeing from development
into actual translation, one thing that we could do
to sort of open the floodgates is to have more prospective
validation that hopefully will
enable us to gather faster evidence for
regulators and then actually deploy these models because we know that some of these
models can be very beneficial.
Okay. So now I'm going to talk about the
actual model,
a bit about the deployment that we did in one of our studies
and how we
went about it.
So I want to go back again to the model life cycle
of pathology AI model, for
example. Of course, you want to do your training, you want to do your thorough
internal validation. Hopefully, you have some amazing
collaborators abroad like we do, and you're able to do external
validation. And I
guess between the external validation, then eventually
regulatory approval, which back in the day we thought, "Okay,
it's not really up to us, the researchers to focus on this.
There's going to be companies doing this, and they'll
worry about it."
I think things have changed, and we now are
proposing that we should do prospective validation
as part of the development
life cycle of the model.
And so this prospective validation has two components that I'm going to talk about
a little bit. The infrastructure side of things, the actual AI
models, your compute environment,
and how you run the silent trial,
and then the actual silent trial design.
Understanding your clinical niche,
simulating
your trial to fine-tune it,
essentially, and then actually running it.
Okay, so the first component is the deployment infrastructure.
I'm assuming you have a
good model that you want to deploy.
You obviously need to be deeply integrated with your
site's
data flows. On one end, you have to have access to the
LIS, the Laboratory Information System, so you can look for
cases that you need to run your model on.
You also need to have access to the digitized slides.
And it seems simple, but I don't know how many
people here could do this today.
Maybe not many.
And then on the other hand, you also need to have access to some
sort of compute. Maybe it's in the cloud, maybe you have a cluster
on-site. And essentially what you're doing is scanning your
LIS, finding cases that match your criteria,
getting those slides, and then orchestrating
these inference runs.
And a funny story. We did this for this paper that I'm going to talk about a
little bit. And we ran it, now we published it,
and a few months later, everything broke down because
it relied on a specific LIS and the institution made the decision of
changing it.
So now we spend a little bit more time in trying to
abstract all the core logic,
and so that this could be more portable.
And so
this is the version that now we're using ourselves and
that we use also with our partners
when we're going to deploy certain trials in the future.
So in theory, this should be more usable.
And
the logic of the course stays the same, but we develop different adapters for
different sites.
Okay,
so now an actual example, and I'm going to talk about this paper from last
year where we showed
how this model that we trained for predicting EGFR status
behaves when we deployed it.
So
this model, yes, predicts EGFR status for lung
adenocarcinoma from whole slide images.
We give it the slide, outputs a score.
I'm going to touch on
the progression now from the preliminary work that we had to do
to
be able to
feel confident that this would work,
the design of the trial,
simulation, then deployment.
Okay, so this is a summary of maybe four
years.Where
originally started maybe around 2019,
2018.
There was an NYU paper in 2018 showing some of
the earlier results on predicting
mutations from H&E from the NYU team.
And
we said, "Okay, let's gather the best cohort." At the time it was MSK,
so we leveraged MSK Impact,
got a huge cohort,
and
gathered both internal and external data through collaborators in
different countries across the continents.
So that's the getting the data. The modeling component,
we developed this model here. It's very simple
structure. I guess you got a foundation model,
a slight aggregator, a classifier.
So you'll see these, I don't know, 1,000 papers every year like this.
I guess the main difference here is that we
fine-tuned everything end to end,
which is not commonly done. And I think
we were able to extract pretty significant gains in performance by doing
that.
And now we have a model. So we
do internal and external validation, and it looks pretty good.
So we see no
drop in performance, essentially.
And at this point, after many years, we're pretty happy.
And we said, "Okay, let's try to deploy."
And the first thing, and hopefully something that
you don't think about at this point, but at the very beginning, is
when and where do you want to deploy this?
So what's the clinical niche that you are inserting your model
into? And so in this particular case, it's kind of straightforward.
This is the gold standard lung adenocarcinoma workflow,
simplified. But essentially, if you're
diagnosed with lung adenocarcinoma, every guideline says
you have to do NGS to see if you have some of these
targetable mutations. Particularly, if you have EGFR, you should
undergo TKI therapy.
In practice, though, that's not what happens.
So in the low-resource setting,
what happens is that maybe you don't have access to NGS,
and then you will never get that TKI therapy.
This setting,
I'm not going to talk about this, but we are planning to touch on
this in the future.
On the other end of the spectrum, in high-resource
settings, you do have access to NGS, for example, MSK or Mount
Sinai.
On top of that, because the oncologists want to get results faster,
they
have developed rapid testing.
And the rapid testing has some pros.
Now, instead of waiting for a couple of weeks of the NGS, you get
some results in one to two days.
And if the test is specific enough, you may start TKI therapy earlier, for
example.
On the other hand, though, they systematically miss some mutation types
because some of these are PCR-based.
Most importantly, though, it exhausts tissue for NGS.
And in lung, now these biopsies are already tiny.
The tissue is scant, so
preserving tissue is very important.
And so if you don't have any more tissue for NGS, then they may have to
re-biopsy the patient, and in some cases,
they never undergo NGS. So this is very bad.
So a potential solution on where we thought we could insert an
AI model in the clinical workflow is to have a
computational biomarker, by definition non-exhaustive, and so
we could avoid these rapid tests,
or maybe replace them eventually.
Another part of understanding the clinical niche is that you have to understand
the clinical workflow at the site.
So this is, for example, a situation at MSK.
And it's important to understand to
know exactly where in the workflow the model would fit
and what would be the triggers that
start the inference of the model, for example.
So the way it works at MSK is that after a
diagnosis, there's going to be a separate molecular accession,
and that's where, in our trial design, we start the clock.
Now, the molecular accession triggers both the rapid test
workflow but also the NGS workflow.
And then we'll see in our cellin trial, this same
input will trigger our
computational biomarker.
Okay.
So now we had a model,
and with certain performance now, we want to deploy it.
How
does this actually happen? So we thought that we have essentially two
knobs at this point. We have a
high sensitivity
regime of the model and a high
specificity regime of the model.
So when the model score is low in the high
sensitivity MPV threshold, if the score is
lower than a certain threshold, then we say, "Okay, we're very sure
that this is negative," and vice versa.
Which means that essentially, if we want to simulate a deployment, we have two
main parameters here, and then we can plot everything on a
2DUh, space where we
have the MPV and the PPV
thresholds here.
And at the same time, we can then calculate interesting things.
For example, we can calculate the
negative,
the MPV and the PPV, but also the amount of
rapid tests that we would avoid. And this is what
you see here on the left at a global level.
Then, of course, we want to
overlay the gold standard workflow, which in
this case is
the rapid test.
And this is represented by these isolines in sort of
magenta and cyan.
And of course, we want to be at least as good, no?
So
you go to the top right corner there, and we
identify
arbitrarily
this
line in gold and certain thresholds along the
line where we're going to essentially
perform and report with the results.
And this is
also retrospective data. We called it the pre-trial data here.
So if we do that, then we can show
these performance metrics, assisted negative predictive
value, assisted positive predictive value, and rapid test
reduction in the
simulation with the retrospective data, pre-trial data.
Then we actually started the trial, as I mentioned before,
and these are the results that we got, essentially very similar,
which we were very happy about. And
from this, we gather that we can essentially reduce
by about 43%
the amount of rapid tests by keeping the same gold standard
performance characteristics of this workflow.
And we're also very happy that a few months later,
a completely different group performed sort of an independent
third-party validation of our model,
and the performance was pretty robust.
We were
very, very happy about that.
So for us, the next steps are going to be
run multi-center silent trials. So we're partnering,
building collaborations, and hopefully we can
run these silent trials for every single model that we're going to
develop in the future.
We're going to do this on additional biomarkers.
We're already working on a more comprehensive panel for lung and
other
somatic targetable alterations.
We're going to focus a lot on the low-resource settings, where this could be even
more beneficial.
And
I think we're actually try to seek approval for
deploying this in the clinic, at least in our hospitals
at Mount Sinai and at MSK as a
laboratory-developed test.
And
a quick summary, there is a
persistent gap between development and adoption of AI
models.
There is an urgent clinical need. I hope
that came across.
And one bottleneck certainly, I think, is validation, and
one way to overcome that could be
showing prospective data, and hopefully that will really
boost deployment in the future.
With that, I want to thank you for your attention.
Fantastic talk. Thank you. It really gives a
tangible sense of how close it could be to deploy
AI-based digital biomarkers in the clinic.
So we have time for questions. You can use the QR
code online or to ask the questions
online, which I'll moderate, or come up and visit one of the
microphones
on either side.
All right. Great talk. I was just wondering, did you
look at the cases where your model fails
and examine if there is
another mutation
that either interacts or causes the model to
make
erroneous detection?
In failed cases, what
other
mutation may be causing that, that is
interacting?
Thank you. Yeah, that is definitely very interesting, and
it's part of
the life cycle of the models.
For this, we were focusing on
clinical usability,
but I certainly hope that we are able to gain insight into
some biological mechanism. We didn't uncover
anything so far, but if we do, certainly that would be
amazing, and I think a lot of people are really interested in
using digital and computational pathology to uncover some biological
insight. And I think the next talk is going to be
very interesting for that.
Ben?
Hi, Benjamin Epkins, Princess Margaret.
Great talk. I was wondering,
Alex mentioned biases
and batch effects in his talk, and I think that's
something we should always look at, whether it's digital pathology or otherwise.
But in your case, especially in the deployment, how do you
Investigate that? How do you monitor and what do you do if you find a
bias or a batch effect?
Yeah, that's great.
Well, I'm going to do a little plug here.
Mount Sinai is the largest health system
in the New York Metro area, which is one of the most diverse
in the US, certainly. And so we have
the opportunity to really investigate these things, whereas in other
hospitals, maybe you don't have the data to look at this.
So some of the things we will usually do is to stratify by
different
variables and see if there is any disparity in the
performance. That's certainly something that
can be done. Another thing that we're
studying for a while, I guess, at this point is
try to understand
if there is at all any signal. Now, what Alex was
showing before, trying to predict maybe self-reported race
from the slide, and if that is possible, why?
Is it really biological? Is it different disease
presentation? That sort of thing.
And so I think Mount Sinai will have the opportunity to investigate, but
that's work in progress.
Thank
you. Please.
Hi, I'm Lodovica Zullo from Gustave Roussy. I have a question.
I've seen, at least to my knowledge, that most of the models that
try to predict
EGFR mutations reaches always a plateau at
0.85, 87, and
there is nothing that has ever improved this 0 curve.
Why do you think it happens?
First of all, I think
when you start,
I guess we shouldn't have any expectation that it should be possible at all.
So what's the maximum level of performance that we can get
from H&E? Maybe we're reaching a plateau for this specific task,
and we don't understand why, really. No.
It's a really difficult question.
So I don't know,
and I don't think anybody knows.
Thank you.
And different tasks have different levels of performance, and some are easier,
some are harder. Maybe our modeling is not good enough, but maybe
the signal is just not there in the H&E.
Thanks.
I think also, I'll just-- Gabriele, your AUROC
curves are pretty symmetrical. So, in the
situations where your model, where Eagle is
incorrect,
it's roughly symmetrical false positives and false negatives, right?
That was at least my interpretation.
So my point is there may be different biologies that would,
or different instances where the biology leads to a false
positive or a false negative in terms of genotype and phenotype being
associated or not associated. So it's going to be interesting to
learn more about that as the years come.
Yeah, there's plenty of work to do.
Please.
Thanks for the great talk. Michael Wiegert from Center for Tumor Diseases,
Heidelberg.
I was wondering what would be your ideal threshold for
benchmarking such an approach. Would it be
enough to make these retrospective silent
trials to convince people that this is enough, or would it
be non-inferiority trials?
Or would it be a prospective trial and show that these patients
even benefit?
Could you speculate on what we need as a benchmark to get this
into clinic?
Yeah.
That's the main question. What's enough, I think,
probably depends on the task.
I guess I didn't go into detail, but one of the slide was about the
guidelines from ESMO in Europe. And what they
say is that... Well, I guess I should describe it.
There is the class A, B, and C,
and
the EGFR one is B because it's a known
biomarker. What changes is the input.
Instead of using NGS,
you use
H&E. And for those, because it's a known biomarker, they argue that
you don't need a clinical trial because
it's a
well-established biomarker.
Whereas if you go to the level C that they
describe, it's completely novel, and they argue for that,
maybe you do need a clinical trial.
But I think the jury's still out, and that's going to probably be
case by case. So
our approach is that we're going to do as much
validation as we can, both retrospective and prospective, as a silent trial,
multicenter, hopefully, and let's see.
We're just starting, I guess, so we'll see if it
pans out.
Terrific.
Well, if there are no further questions, we can thank our speaker once again and
move on to our third talk.
All right. Our third speaker is Professor Lihua Wang
from MD Anderson Cancer Center,
who will give her talks on looking even further into the future
on how we'll use digital pathology to cure cancer.
Thank you so much, Alex, and good afternoon, everyone, and thank you
so much for staying. And this is my
disclosures, and I divided my talk in two parts.
First, I'm-
I'm going to talk about how to integrate AI pathology, spatial
multi-omics, and
then AI-enabled biomarker discovery.
In the first part, I will be talking about how to leverage deeper
learning-based approaches for spatial mixed data processing,
multi-modal spatial data analysis, and integration in 2D and 3D.
And for the second part, I will be talking about decoding
the complex tissue architecture and how to translate
our complex insights from the spatial tissues to
biomarkers.
And most of this is unpublished. So for the audience
who might be less familiar with spatial multi-omics,
here's what you're able to see. This is a sequence-based approach.
On the left, you see the H&E images that is paired with spatial
transcriptomics. And you see the U map of the spatial transcriptomics
data that reflects how similar they are of each spot.
You see close to 10,000 spots here.
On the right side is the high-resolution pathology annotation.
So you see here the normal epithelium is in bright
pink, and well-differentiated tumor cells in the light pink.
The green cells are tumor cells,
they are poorly differentiated. You also see some cells in blue, they are tumor
cells at invasive front. So in this way, you can really
align the molecular signals and in the natural
tissue microenvironment and understand how these
morphological features link with the expression profiles and
other key signal pathways.
So there are many methods have been developed to leverage AI
pathology for spatial omics. So there are many methods
for different purposes, and this is a very simple
example, and you could leverage
this useful application. You could leverage their deep
learning-based approach
to analyze images and to convert their
pathology annotation as well as gene expression from spot
level to pixel level to generate high-resolution
images. And also for their sequencing-based
spatial transcriptomics, you could leverage the CNN
segmentation model to perform single-cell
segmentation on the paired H&E images.
That will help you impute gene expression
and to fill the gaps between the spots and convert their
spot-level tissue maps to single-cell level spatial maps.
And also for the high-resolution
beam level spatial transcriptomics, such as Visum HD, you can do something
similar. This will allow you to generate a
single-cell level spatial high-resolution transcriptomics
data. This will substantially enhance
spatial architecture detection and downstream
analysis.
So I'd like to talk about something very new, and this is
led by the spatial profiling group of our GIMMS 3D
team, supported by NCI ATAN product
and by Luisa and Dania,
who are amazing pathologists. We generated
the same sections, spatial transcriptomics, proteomics, and
post H&E images. So with
histology, transcriptomics, proteomics in the same section.
This provide a unique opportunity to integrate these modalities.
And we could leverage their deep learning-based
approaches to align the modalities.
To first, we could align largely the
compartments. So it is important to first align the compartment because the
tissue could move, and they could detach, and
the two modalities, even the same tissue section, they may not always
match. And most critically is to align the
modality at a single-cell resolution.
And to achieve single-cell matching, distance
alone is insufficient. You have to consider the
distance, the similarity of cell typing
from the two modalities, as well as the topology.
So this will help us generate a cell-cell matching probability
metrics to help align the data from two modalities at a
single-cell resolution.
And
so I'm also going to share some very exciting progress we
have made in the 3D. And tumor biology is
inherently three-dimensional, and with 2D views,
we're not able to capture the full picture of the
complexity of the tumor ecosystem.
So you could leverage this deeper learning approach and
to learn across the tissue sections.
So this will help you to
register the serial sections.
And we can generate 3D molecular
maps of human tumors. This is a real human tumor.
You can see 2 million cells. They are high resolution. You can look at every cell.
You can look at the signals. Here you see B cell and the T cell, how they are
aligned, and the key signals, CXCL13, CXCL5, that
is important for tissue infrastructure formation.
You can look at basically every single cell and other key signals.
This will help us link the structure to function.
And similarly, you can apply this approach and to infer the
spatial compartment and register them across
their serial sections. So in this way, we could get
a very nice view of the tumor. Now you look at this
tissue
almost like a glass box. You can see through the
tissue, look at the major compartment, their spatial relationships.
This will help us understand the complex cell organization,
and especially across different compartments
andNo, the first part will be very
short, and the main focus will be the second part.
I'm going to switch the gears and talk about the second part.
But for the first part, what you see largely is in the part of
the Spiral. And if you are interested in learning
more,
my data scientist, Yinghe Liu, will be presenting Spiral on Tuesday
afternoon, the poster number is 5505.
And the second part, I'm going to talk about how to decode in tissue
architecture and translates the insights into biomarkers.
So basically, the spatial omics field
is evolving amazingly fast.
You see many new platforms, many new approaches.
Almost every day, their papers come out.
So with these latest approaches allow you to segment every
single cell by leveraging multimodality,
morphological markers,
multimodal segmentation plus AI.
So precisely segment every single cell and align the transcript within the
cell. This will help you identify the identity of the cell,
and what type of cell, and understand the
phenotypical states. And with that, basically, you could
go beyond and in this complex tissue, and you
can see not only tumor cells, but you see their environments, and generally the
high-resolution single-cell map of the tumor tissue.
This will also allow you to understand how the cells are organized, how they
interact, what are the signal flow between them, and
identify the spatial features that matter in clinic.
So I'd like to give you example, because this is a
large tissue. It's basically one centimeter by one
centimeter.
The complexity exists but is hidden.
I'd like to show you. At the bottom, you see there are many different cell types.
Basically, with this ultra-highplex spatial
transcriptomics, you could define 20 or 50 or even more
cell types and cell states and better understand the complex tumor tissue.
And let's look at one tissue, look at the tumor
core. You don't need to look at that many colors. Just look at the pink colors.
There's plasma cell, there's macrophages in orange, and CAF in yellow.
In the tumor core, you see is a pretty much CAF.
They are very close to the tumor cells.
And I can also see the aggregates of the macrophages.
And let's move to the tumor interface.
You see aggregates of more macrophages here in this case.
Let's look at the other case. For this case in the tumor core, you don't basically
see the macrophages. You see
a higher abundance of the CAF.
But as the periphery, the interface, you see
still a high abundance macrophages.
So basically, why I want to show the macrophages, you guys
maybe learn. So macrophage is becoming our emerging
interesting target and platform for cell therapy, but we don't yet
fully understand the spatial organization with the macrophages and their
functional states.
So this will allow us to define them.
For this tissue, if you look at the map on the right side, I hope you can see the
green color and red color. The green color, one type of
macrophages, they are immunosuppressive.
They are characterized by high expression of the TIM-2,
CCL18, and they form aggregates in the tumor region.
And about the green macrophages, a high expression CXCL9 and
CXCL10. They are immune to military.
They are largely at the tumor periphery.
And if you quantify them, now you can see the TIM-2, the
peak is in the tumor region. CXCL9 macrophages,
you see the progressive decrease when they get into the tumor
center. But on the other hand, you can see the FAP positive might have, it is
progressive increase. Let's look at the other
sample. You see a different type of macrophage that is CSF1R positive,
is also immunosuppressive, characterized by high expression with
CD163. And you can see the different
spatial distribution pattern of these two different
type of macrophages. One is scattered in the tumor region, the other
form aggregates at the tumor interface.
So this will give us a idea how the overall landscape of
the macrophages in the tumor to
help us better development the approaches to target these macrophages.
When you look at this together, this different way of illustration, you
see these two type of macrophages in the same tissue.
They are spatially aggregated. They have different distribution patterns.
So it is important to understand the entire
spatial architecture, because in addition to the macrophages and the CAF, their T
cell, their DC, their B cells, and many other
cells. It's very complex tissue environment,
and the single cell population will never able to give you a full picture.
So people try to identify and define the spatial
archetypes will give you a high level view of the tissue
environment and correlate that with the clinical
outcomes. So,
in addition to the spatial organization, important, the critical part
is understand the spatial interaction, the cell-cell
interaction, because
I feel like this is
important to move beyond of the cell center review to
understand how cell interact in the tissue.
And because
the tumor is not a random collection of cells.
The cells talk to each other. They're sending or receiving signals
consistently.And
so the cell form niches, the functional niches,
you see many of them in the tumor tissue.
They may play different roles. They influence therapy
response, disease progression. We don't yet fully understand them.
They could be
considered as a fundamental functional unit of the
tissue. And if you are interested in learning more about this,
just please read our review article in "Cancer Cell." I'm going to
briefly highlight two of the special niches, and the
first is the CAF. As we know,
cancer-associated fibroblasts have been considered as a promising target
for over a decade, but the effort targeting CAF as a
whole has not really met our expectation because they are so
highly diverse in their functional
states. And
so in this work,
we have a talented postdoc, that was a data scientist, who defined
four different spatial organizations of the CAF.
They associate with clinical outcomes, so they are not only
biologically relevant but also clinically relevant.
And you can learn more about this work by reading this paper.
And I want to also share that we're developing
the AI model
that can help us detect the CAF tumor niches
directly from the H&E images and quantify the abundance and distribution
of these niches and understand
this tumor. And another niche that I want to
highlight is the tissue infrastructures. Why does it matter?
Because it is closely associated with immunotherapy response.
This is the work published in 2020 by our team, highlights
its correlation with the therapy response, clinical outcomes.
And to take that further, we developed this AI framework, can help
us detect,
segment, and phenotype TIS
from the spatial transcriptomics.
And this is very scalable, can be applied to a few hundred or
thousands of images simultaneously.
And
we are building our all-in-one framework
we call the Omni-TIS, that allow us to detect and
phenotype TIS from different
modalities. For example, spot level, spatial transcriptomics,
single-cell level spatial transcriptomics, H&E images.
By putting all this together, I hope that it is useful for the community.
This will also include modules for
classification based on the maturization stage and the TIS-based
patient stratification. The first part of this work has been accepted.
Hopefully, we'll see it soon. And I want to show
you a high-resolution single-cell level
TIS map. This is what you see. This is a mature TIS.
And you can learn
where are these different types of cells.
There's many different type of cells. It's not just B and T cells.
So to make TIS and their multiple cell populations,
they have different spatial locations.
I'm not going to play the full video.
And so just put it in a clinical context.
This is in collaboration with our Allison study, Dr. Pamela Summer.
And we analyzed this TIS responders, non-responders
from patients with renal cell carcinoma.
You can see this is a comparison, not only the density
of the TIS are different between the responder, non-responders, but
also you see the difference in maturization stage.
You see quite different composition of
the TIS states in addition to their
density.
So that is important. Also, I want to mention about the
vascular structures. It is very important to understand vascular
structures,
but it is so complex. And I have a graduate
student, Jiahui, he's building this AI model, very simple model,
and to detect and phenotype these
vascular structures in a big tissue like this one,
can quickly identify where are those vessels and the different type of the
vessels, and
to learn the neighborhood of the vessels.
So we are about to define different functional states of the vessels.
For example, I select three regions. You see they're different.
Some of them are stroma associated, some of them are immune enriched, and
you see a lot is tumor associated in the tumor region.
For the immune-enriched vascular structure, they are
important for immune cell trafficking in the tumor,
so it is critical to understand them.
And lastly, I want to mention there are many, many AI models,
and to allow you to do pseudo staining
to impute gene expression, impute protein expression, and
impute spatial niches. You can apply a simple model like
this one. This is a uni-based model, allow you to just
infer
their spatial architecture from H&E images.
It works beautifully. And further, I think it is
important to have a little bit granularity. This is what you see here.
This is a TCGA samples, and we are able to
define more kind of higher granular
spatial architectures. For this one, you can see the tumor
region. It's enriched with stroma cell, their
CAF. And in this tumor, you see different
distribution of the CAF from the other one.
You may see some other colors, the cluster number eight, their
bright red color, that is enriched with
exhausted T cells in the tumor region.
So this is able to capture this kind of details. And this one is different.
In the tumor center, you see a lot of CAF, but it's different type of CAF.
You see vascular structures in the tumor core.
But in the periphery tumor, they are pretty cold.
You don't see immune cells or stroma cells.
This tells you different spatial architecture.
So this level of details are important.
Basically, I have one last slide to show youThis is in collaboration
with Dr. Daphne Meru,
a dear collaborator. So this is in our colon cancer liver
mats. It's important to understand not only the big micro
mats, but important is the minimal radio disease.
You call it the small micro mats. As you see here, you could
detect this at a single cell resolution.
And to reach this sensitivity is critical for clinical application
because patient with this MRD has poor survival.
And to wrap it up,
I want to leave you with these
slides.
It is the perfect time to leverage spatial omics and AI to
build a global view of the tissue ecosystem, to understand
how the cells are spatially organized, how they talk to each other.
We don't yet fully understand their language, right?
So how their spatial organization and interaction
change in response to therapy,
so that we can uncover the spatial principle
that govern tumor cell behavior, therapy response.
With that, I'd like to thank my team, especially the people
listed here, my amazing team and wonderful collaborators.
And
the funding agency. I received very generous support from
NCH Time Breast Cancer, our Allison
Institute, Data Science Institute, PRSC,
many others, and the patient and families.
Thank you all so much. I want to
highlight basically,
so our GIMMS 3D team and Dr. Miao Li will be
present on the AI pathology and the spatial omics on
Monday. And our Dr. Ti Hong
Huang will be talk further about the non-disruptive
3D4D technology on Wednesday morning.
I hope to see you guys there. Thank you so much.
I'll be happy to take any questions.
That's a fantastic talk.
Graphically, visually, I think that you are owed a residency at the
Sphere in Las Vegas. It's so beautiful.
We have time for questions. How about up at the microphone?
Hello. It was a great talk. I just wondering how much we
learn from 3D, how much we have missed by 2D
experiments?
That's a great question.
That's also the question I ask my team and myself,
and it is very complex tissue ecosystem.
For example,
TIs. Let's use TIs as example. You see TIs within the 2D
tissue section, you see them small or big, they are separated.
But when you look at the 3D, I'm not sure if you pay attention to the red color
and
we have this 3D of the TIs in that video I played.
You see some of them are interconnected like a mountain.
And that will basically give me
some idea. And when we quantify TIs and the
correlate with clinical outcomes, we typically count the number of
TIs, or we quantify their proportion of the
size of the TIs. But that may not be really
they're reliable in term of their clinical biomarkers.
Let me think about maybe their spatial volume of the
TIs matters because it's aggregates of T cells and B
cells, right? I think that is simple example, but there are many
other, I think,
populations in the microenvironments there, especially the
vascular structures. I think 3D is unique and
a powerful way to understand that.
Good. We'll go to the west microphone for the next question.
Hello. That was a beautiful question.
Apologies if...
Beautiful presentation, I'm sorry. Apologies if my question is a little bit naive.
So for the cell annotation, do you use any
in-house list of biomarkers for annotate the
cell origin, or you use databases?
Can you specify the platform as we use different approaches for the
data from different platform.
Okay. For the spatial transcriptomics.
Okay.
For the single cell resolution, you just treat that as their
single cell sequencing. Because you have pretty good gene
coverage, you can define the cell
populations, the major cell population very easy, and for the
cell states, for example, you can define six or eight different type of T
cells. That will also feasible
based on their expression of the canonical markers.
And one way is to define based on their
knowledge, the other is transfer learning.
So by integrating your spatial data with single cell sequencing data that is
carefully annotated, you could transfer the label.
You could also transfer the label from single cell sequencing to the spot level
or even beam level with transcriptomics and learn
that.
There's many different approaches, we could discuss
offline.
Okay. Thank you. Appreciate it.
But that's a critical part. If you mess up a cell typing,
the downstream will be totally different.
Great. Let's go over to this.
Thanks.
Fabulous. I have two short questions.
One is,
so you said these images contain signaling information that you can
extract. So for example, if you treat cancer patients with RAS
inhibitor and so on, could you actually see the
signaling being inhibited?
That's a great question, and depends on the modality.
You can leverage the transcriptomics, proteomics,
metabolomicsAnd epigenetics.
Mm-hmm.
And also, I think the resolution and the courage are
the key factors.
That's the key factors determining how much information you can gather
from these spatial modalities.
Typically, especially with the emerging whole transcriptomics
platform, you could capture a few thousand transcripts.
Some of them are highly relevant, and a part of the key signals will
allow you to infer their key signaling
pathways, like what I showed is SIXL13, SIXL5,
but there are many other ligand receptors.
They are included in their panel design.
You can also design your custom panel.
And I think one really limited modality will be,
I
hope to see improvement is the cytokine.
I hope in the near future we can see a more robust platform to
capture those cytokines. That is important for us to understand the
cell-cell interactions.
Yeah. We developed 100 reagents for cytokine IHC, but later
I can discuss. Second question is
spatial proteomics, right? So
how correlative are they with transcripts, and could you
resolve also subcellular localizations of these proteins, for example,
signaling the receptor cluster at one part of the-
That's another great question. If you look at RNA and protein, they are not always
consistent, but they are complementary.
For example, CD31, you see the beautiful protein, and with
spatial protein, you can capture vascular structures.
But for transcripts, you're not able to find a single transcript that's
unique to identify endothelial cells.
And vice versa. You can leverage spatial transcriptomics
that's not available at a protein level because
it's limited by the antibody availability. They are complementary.
I hope to leverage multiple modalities, of course, that has to fit your budget.
Let's go to the west microphone.
Very nice talk, Lingua.
I was thinking that, two questions, one is related to the
proteomics, and
without that information or without the other modalities,
is it possible to come up with an incomplete biological
understanding? And the other question is, we all know that even the
gastric cancer you're doing within H10,
how difficult it is to understand the
cell fate over time, right? So is it
possible to stitch together your spatial
transcriptomics data from different patients that were driven
by, I don't know, maybe the same gene or something like that, same
mutation,
to come up with an understanding of
how the evolution took place?
Great questions. I appreciate the insights.
So, yes, we have to leverage additional modalities that I didn't
show you. For example, the mutation analysis and
for the spatial,
either RNA or protein, you need to understand the
evolution of their tumor cells and tumor cell clones.
And for the context of the hereditary gastric cancer, what we did
is in the adjacent tissue section, we did
multiple laser microdissection to capture
20 or 40 foci, including the precursor lesions, invasive tumor
niche from their
episadial to the submucosal layer, to the muscle layer
to capture the different
tumor cell populations. This will allow us to understand their
evolution to build the phylogenetic tree.
For example, in their entire gastric, they all have the
germline CDH1 mutations. They are all high risk.
Why that particular foci transform into
signet ring cell carcinoma, and why that foci
will invade deeper into the muscle layer?
I think to integrate their spatial genomics and transcriptomics,
proteomics will be the key to
generate these deep insights.
Of course, it's about discovery for the downstream as
spatial perturbation, organoids, mouse models.
The validation is a key step
basically to convert
correlative to causal
inference. I think that's a critical step.
Right. Thank you.
Last question for the session.
No pressure.
So I was wondering, we always talk about biomarkers from those
spatial data in 3D and more complicated.
Beyond colocalization of cell types,
do you have a generalizable approach to take the
spatial information and distill it into a number we can use as
a biomarker? What's your approach here?
Great question. I think we have a couple of papers coming out.
I hope that will change the way how we think about the biomarker.
So typically, we see a single gene or protein or a gene
signature or other special features.
I feel like we could leverage the spatial
features and at a higher level to build our
composite signature, and that maybe work
even more robust
in terms of the biomarkers. Of course, has to be clinically
employable.
Think about, is there a way how we can translate
simply to the clinic?
I feel like that's a great question.
That's definitely the field I think we are heading to with spatial
multi-omics.
Thank you so much for all of the questions.
Well, what a great way to end. Thanks again.
Let's thank our speakers again and conclude the session.
Thank
you
all. That's great. Fantastic. I know all the
questions. A lot of great questions.
Am I in
that?